welcome to this video playing al-khatib
this is qatar qatar okay so we have a
Toria tech Bishop g5 now maybe if quick
Queen B 6 to irritate him I can play
Quincy to Yama okay now probably I
should stick to two simpler measures
against this opening but ok [ __ ]
should be in pretty pretty decent shape
it's not particularly active what I
played here who is a lovely night before
is amazing before he probably had any
had a check but surprised that he would
allow that switching and staffing office
is good Bishop hmm should I take him Jim
takes on b7 at the end probably not a
good idea I mean ok it's a it's a bit
surprising that he allowed this night
before it so it's not like I'm quickly
winning or anything threatening 97 so
probably have to move the bishop he
might have f4 f5 maybe
but I'm now close to taking yeah it's
rugby one can answer by Quincy three so
b2 is is hanging now ok so hmm i can try
to to double
okay let's let's play ambitiously and
try to grab the bishop am now the idea
is to night XD 5 could be irritating
take on g3 night XD five and i can take
CA that's really an issue okay okay drop
the crack protect c8 what I want to do
is is take play f6 and then get the
bishop to g6 okay this was my attention
anyway and I don't really get what is
doing geez f6 and where are you going to
g4 this looks a very strange an IG 6
Bishop d6 leads nowhere I have King g7
next maybeee for him now possible
Wow Bishop here what what's the response
to that just am just in this big
diagonal I mean II for I can take player
5 and win apiece at least I hope at
least I hope I'm seeing this correctly
ok so now i can i can win one of the
ropes IAM should should do that really
ok how does he I can how does he get any
counter play maybe Queen g7 with the
intention to play five should I go f5
block this maybe I can even night come c
5 I can take it with the bishop and my
plan should be to double on the C file
and push the beam on so 95 I just I just
a cough oh yeah we'll look at that
but how dangerous is it if I take take
him
I stupid I should have thought about it
at least check heart still hard to
believe that it should should be fatal
from me
yeah I think I still should be okay can
give this chick I just run to e7 the
nights and druke not really play much
night a night coming to e5 wherefore I
can take check
no it's not totally easy but it should
be ok for black I know I can take play
Queen deform and possibly look aged
eight I wait where did whether it is
much simpler I can check here now he
needs to run into a pin or or kicking f1
Queen d3s I thought totally winning
isn't it jack he has still has this
check here but now he's really pin down
so I can give a check here Wendy still
Queen g5 I can want to run to run over
to c6 Jack rook is pinned so rock t two
is impossible check
now look ga ga Luke g84 Queen takes g3
he has no check now that's made I can go
to g1 hands not a direct made
possibly just marry queen d-force better
main Queenie 7 Queen g3 king g one I
don't like resins yeah i don't i don't
see how i don't see an eric mate if he
goes here at least check what is the
mate here I queen age too yeah of course
I can I can give the check here of
course check check this this stuff
should shoot p.m. it should be a maid in
the end check check check and this one
ok let's let's check this was really
curious k around here I think it's about
equal and come wants to take on be too I
thought that maybe I'm not very well
coordinated no idea who I thought this
one actually look piayed with the clear
edge for black interesting ok ok ok ok
hmm what I didn't see here at all is
that after this I can just take I mean
this is protected by the Queen I thought
after Luke takes b7 sorry after rube
takes b7 why does have this threat but
it's not really happening and then this
is indeed quite good one problem is that
if you go here this is excellent for
black
check and yeah this is this is very nice
for black so I played it I didn't play
it well I should really take them g5 was
probably better and still grabbing up I
didn't I didn't really take this too
much into account still this is a good
position I can f3 is already a slightly
weird though i FF 4 SS is very strange I
mean Bishop g6 it's very clearly my next
move and why I 42 to give up the
exchange and good here here I just need
to be neat to be precise and I didn't
take that into account button sets
fortunately enough not working Oh Who
interesting King h8 is the move winning
this is not winning wow he could have
taken only four Wow
that's a shocker really yeah okay I
cannot take this check here who get
mated yeah if i take c to jesse's to be
a draw according to the [ __ ] which looks
very believable I mean I'm glad that I'm
not mated check check check 12 drawn
it's very strong no I didn't see it at
all Wow ok check after this probably i'm
ok no Queen age for a draw ok I see the
comp wants to do this again I didn't
really yeah I didn't take into account
that i can go in the corner this is why
i went sorry why I went towards the
center but it seems that this is check
this is now a draw I actually thought
that I can't have this but oops 95 seems
to be oops of course not I wanted to
take Jack now thought here here I should
have something but it turns out that
Queen edge wife is probably too strong a
threat rook c5 seems to be wrong yeah
check amazing shadow really were Jack
points to this channel here I am winning
tough tough night XD for would have been
very shocking relief ok thanks for
watching